this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman
and also [ __ ] that should not be this
week this is the moment in a film where
you look at something you say that can't
be right there's people who work on this
film day and night for months and they
let this slip through the cracks and yet
time and time again we find them it's
[ __ ] that should not be this week's [ __ ]
that should not this week's [ __ ] that
should not be is from Greg town of Dover
Delaware he brings up an excellent point
and I'm glad he did he says can we clean
up some year-end business a while ago
you talked about some [ __ ] that should
not be from the 1976 sci-fi classic
Logan's Run but I remember there was
some technical difficulty you never
showed the clip I'm a huge fan of this
film and I'd love to know what you were
talking about and to see it he's right I
remember this specifically we're having
technical difficulties running with [ __ ]
that should not be and it was
specifically a moment that I never
noticed before until someone brought it
to my attention
Logan's run the science fiction film if
you've never seen it it's about people
who can't live past the age of 30 once
you're 30 they kill you in this society
so these two young people go on the run
and there's a lot of gunplay a lot of
bad Star Trek type days totally [ __ ]
get the little girl have to call an
arrow and [ __ ] no that's a different
film that's Hunger Games you're thinking
of something else
so anyway this is a scene where Michael
York a young handsome Michael York you
may remember him from the Austin Powers
movies he is running away with Jenny
Agutter and there's a firefight going on
and this scene for some reason I guess
everyone supposed to be getting shot and
blowing up and people are on fire but
there's a guy first of all you hear his
screen which sounds like something out
of a Three Stooges movie it's just give
you an approximation it's that and then
he runs into frame and his ass is on
fire the rest of him is fine it's just
his ass is on fire and if you think
someone in the production would say we
can't use this scene cuz there's a guy
runs by who's [ __ ] on fire and that
looks like he had some bad chili there's
no point in us
serious film here but they left it in so
here's the scene from Logan's run we
never got to show you earlier in the
year this is the ass on fire sequence
from Logan's run in the future I guess
you you know it's the perfect
performance though
[Music]
you